we unexpectedly catch sight of ourselves
in a mirror and in an instant thrown
into despair the odd nose the
unsatisfactory hair the sickening
skintone but most of all the only two
familiar deeply gormless needy
expression it feels at such moments as
if every worst fear about us must be
true all our efforts to run away from
our monster self have failed
a hideous specter is for our brief time
on the planet but truly who we are fated
to be crucially feeling ugly is entirely
independent of what anyone actually
looks like there are beauties running
around the world who are sickened by
their looks and grizzled munchkins
breezily at ease with themselves there
are always an infinite number of reasons
to find oneself pleasant or hideous
clever or idiotic so what decides the
matter is never in the end the judgment
of our eyes but the condition of our
souls it is the inner mood that guides
our gaze in its assessment of the face
in the mirror and that projects the
atmosphere of selfishness sleaziness and
furtiveness we locate in our features
therefore we don't when we're sad ever
really need a new set of clothes or a
haircut we require to put it naively and
grandly to be looked at through the eyes
of love by someone who's generous
assessment can rescue us from the
depredations
of self-hatred it's all the more
unfortunate that precisely when we feel
disgusting
it can be so hard to ask another person
for their help we hate ourselves too
much to dare to hope that anyone else
might like us and we may in response to
kind inquiries simply attempt to prove
our dislikable nature through
monosyllabic avoidant grunts we need in
our distressed state for someone else to
explain our condition to the world to
make the case that we are lost and a
aimed not monstrous or mean we may need
for a time at least to let someone
else's words do the work for us at the
School of Life we believe that
confidence is a skill we can learn our
confidence prompt cards are designed to
help us master this mysterious art
you